Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
The big five and the Myers Briggs types.
Both seek to quantify our personalities
through analysis of our behavior
thoughts, decision making, preferences,
perspectives, and the like.
Usually through a self report test.
The two are actually similar
in many important ways and
the Nbti you come out as
either an I or an e introvert
or extrovert and the big five.
This of course correlates with the
extroversion scale and the NBTI.
You're either an n or an s intuitive
or sensor and the big five there's a
correlation with this and the
openness scale in the NBTI.
You're a t or f thinker or a feeler in
the big five this is the agreeableness
scale and Bti Jrp judge or perceiver
big five the conscientiousness scale.
Now granted these two
don't line up perfectly,
which you can see that they are trying
to measure very similar aspects of our
personality which are very core
to who we are and how we live.
You can pretty reasonably expect therefore
that someone who tests as an INTP
line up somewhere in these areas
on the big five and versely,
someone who scores this on the big five
probably will end up as an ist Jay on
the NBTI.
Nevertheless,
it's no secret that the
scientific community strongly
prefers the big five over
the NBTI.
Many people in fact completely dismiss
the Nbti as just being modernized.
Astrology in favor of
the big five. Why? Well,
I've argued against this in the past so
I'm not going to go too much into it in
this video,
but I don't think that it really makes
sense to consider the NBTI modernized
astrology and in strongly
favor the big five.
I mean they operate in a pretty similar
way and measure pretty similar things
granted.
Sure.
The NBTI following mad times
make it seem a little ridiculous,
but you can't always judge something
based off its fan base and yes,
there is the issue that people take
the test two separate times and get two
different results.
Does that mean that these assessments
are a completely whimsical and invalid?
Not necessarily.
We also have to consider that sometimes
the test taker may be at fault,
that there's perhaps an issue with
getting a self aware and intellectually
honest self assessment from
the general population,
but that's of course not the issue
with everyone, which I'll get to.
There was some problems
with both of these tests,
but there are a number of things to the
NBTI Aleks and fails to address that the
big five does not,
which is why the scientific community
really favors it and which is what we're
here to talk about.
The first obvious difference is that the
big five includes a category that the
NBTI does not neuroticism.
This has to do with the amount of time
you spend subjected to negative emotions.
Higher scores tend to feel anxiety,
fear, depression, anger, loneliness,
that kind of stuff.
More often than lower scores in the NBTI.
If you type Imtj that doesn't tell
someone whether you're possibly struggling
with neuroticism, maybe mental
illness even or whether you're not,
but that's a very important part
of who you are and how you live,
especially from the
viewpoint of a psychologist,
whether they're studying an
individual or a population. Secondly,
there's an important difference in how
the results are presented in the big five.
Your results are placed on a
scale intended to represent
your average behavior
and feelings with the NBTI.
I've noticed that some scales have
been implemented in some tests,
but each letter is basically a dichotomy
which to some seems like either or
black or white.
The introversion and extroversion scale
is a pretty simple example of this.
Are you an introvert or an extrovert?
For those of us in one of these areas,
in the big five it's probably pretty
obvious, but for those in this area,
people who exist in the range
of amber version kind of,
it might be a little more unclear, but
the NBTI doesn't always highlight that.
It essentially assigns you I or II and
of course the same situation happens with
the other letters as well. The NBTI
does a good job of giving 16 types,
but it doesn't represent the variation
within each type as well as the big five
does. And so if you're on the border
between two different types in the NBTI,
maybe try taking the big five and see
if you land in the middle is maybe why.
Ultimately both tests can be useful tools,
depending on what you're going for.
But from an academic standpoint,
the big five is the clear winner.
For more videos like this and
video is on many other subjects,
be sure to check up fire of learning
and subscribe. Thank you for watching.